tout le monde prend place
s'il vous plaît
vous pouvez le faire et vous l'avez fait
je vous remercie bravo
bien chers collègues
sur le plaisir de recevoir
ce matin
général d'armée Christian Rodriguez qui
est le directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale ainsi que final de
division relance Amora qui est
commandant de la région de gendarmerie
Pays de la Loire
sur la thématique des menaces et des
agressions subies par les élus locaux
j'indique d'ores et déjà que nous sommes
un peu dans la pénombre parce que notre
audition est retransmise et donc sur le
site internet du Sénat il faut donc que
les conditions techniques soient
remplies merci de votre présence ce
matin je rappellerai simplement les
conditions de cette audition où les
raisons exactement
le maire de Saint-Brévin
a décidé de démissionner ensuite des non
seulement des menaces mais des actes
d'agression dont il a été victime
de son mandat de maire
il avait d'ailleurs alerté plusieurs
reprises les médias et nous avons décidé
ici la commission des lois de comprendre
ce qui s'était passé bien sûr que le cas
particulier
nous intéresse particulièrement Monsieur
Morez étant venu le premier ici en
audition expliquer sa situation
se plaindre de choses mais également
nous faire
l'exégèse très précise de ce qu'il a
vécu et il est bien évident que d'autres
collègues mer se sont manifestés depuis
je pense le maire de Plougrescant
notamment et mais beaucoup d'autres ont
fait savoir que même avait subi des
menaces des pressions voire même été
physiquement
agressé dans le cadre de leur mandat par
un certain nombre de personnes
d'ailleurs qui soient dans des groupes
organisés dit d'extrême droite soit
d'extrême gauche soit sur des individus
je veux dire qu'ils étaient dans les
comportement strictement personnel
nous l'avons auditionné bien sûr nous
avons auditionné également le préfet de
région ainsi que le préfet le
sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire d'ailleurs
dont nous avons appris mais ce n'est pas
un titre de gloire selon certains le
fait que il a été il a changé de
fonction en tous les cas la semaine
dernière
et nous continuons nous remercions en
général d'avoir accepté de venir nous
parler à la fois du cas particulier bien
sûr ce qui explique la présence du
général Zamora mais plus largement
de la situation de l'ensemble des élus
locaux qui aujourd'hui comme beaucoup
d'autres concitoyens d'ailleurs
subissent des actes de violence très
directement souvent pour des motifs
j'allais pas dire fallacieux mais pour
n'importe quelle raison le degré de
violence est en clairement en
augmentation on le ressent parfaitement
pour beaucoup d'entre nous qui ont
exercé des fonctions locales il y a
quelques années de maire
certes il y avait des moments difficiles
mais peut-être jamais à ce point dans le
passage à l'acte et dans la nature de la
violence et dans le passage à l'acte et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes aussi très intéressés en général
d'avoir vos lumières sur ces situations
là sur ce que vous vivez sur ce que vous
constatez nous avons ici à l'initiative
de quelques-uns déposer une proposition
de loi pour pouvoir renforcer la
protection des élus locaux augmenter les
peines encourus bien évidemment mais
nous savons tous ici que c'est important
de le faire ce sera sans doute pas
suffisant il y a beaucoup d'autres
éléments à apporter et votre regard nous
importe voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en propos introductif avant de vous
laisser immédiatement la parole et on va
dire merci de votre présence
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
donc je ce que je vous propose c'est
vous présenter de manière générale
ce que nous faisons et comment nous
considérons nous considérons la relation
entre entre les mers les élus les mers
en particulier et la gendarmerie et puis
le général Zamora pourra revenir
davantage dans le détail sur les points
qui concernent cette triste à faire de
du ancien maire de Saint-Brévin et puis
nous nous livrerons bien sûr à toutes
les questions que vous avez à nous poser
soit d'un ordre général ou
sur le ce qui a motivé en fait les
auditions que vous avez dirigées
alors déjà en préambule
je souhaite
m'associer à
je dirais à la au soutien vis-à-vis de
tous les maires on savait 37 ans que je
suis gendarme et je me tous les jours je
suis heureux de voir qu'on a encore des
mers qui sont engagés malgré le fait que
c'est une ça doit être un véritable
sacerdoce et engagement et vous évoquez
les l'augmentation des faits de violence
et c'est très vrai je donnerais juste
les statistiques sur l'année 2022 mais
avoir aujourd'hui un tel engagement
alors que les mers sont les premiers que
l'on sollicite en particulier quand
quelque chose qui ne va pas ou du moins
que quelqu'un considère ne pas aller
comme il souhaiterait qu'il aille ce qui
est pas forcément la réalité des des
choses en revanche quand quelque chose
se passe bien on en parle quand même
beaucoup moins souvent au maire et d'une
manière générale les mères sont en
première ligne et comme nous avons un
maillage important dans le territoire
c'est un peu le
je dirais le collègue de tous les jours
en fait il doit y avoir une relation
très très forte entre le maire et ses
gendarmes
et c'est aussi pour cela que les propos
que nous allons tenir les réponses que
nous pouvons vous fournir
nous servirons également à nous pour
pour en tirer un retour d'expérience et
voir comment améliorer les choses
vous avez vous évoquiez monsieur le
Président le l'augmentation des fêtes de
violence
on l'observe on a par exemple entre
2022 en 2021 et 2022 on a une
augmentation des des plaintes pour
violence de 32% de la part d'élus pour
près des 3/4 d'entre eux ce sont des
mers
on rajoute 15 % qui concernent des des
adjoints en mer ou des conseils
municipaux en fait on voit bien une
concentration des agressions d'une part
sur les maires et les élus locaux même
si on a eu une phase où les
parlementaires ont également connu une
augmentation du nombre de fèves et c'est
vrai que ramener au volume total
on en a beaucoup beaucoup de communes
donc beaucoup de maires et conseils
municipaux donc mais le moins de 132%
c'est c'est loin d'être rien et et en
fait on observe ça depuis quelques
années
j'essaye d'écrire à chaque maire qui
dépose plainte chez nous et je me rends
compte que j'écris de plus en plus de
courir en fait de de soutien au maire et
ça me fera aussi parce que c'est encore
une fois ce constat il est vraiment il
est flagrant et il nous il nous impacte
très très fortement je fais le lien avec
le l'augmentation des faits de violence
également contre les policiers et les
gendarmes si je regarde uniquement les
faits qui nous concerne nous on a toutes
les 30 minutes qui a un refus de
tempérer
toutes les quatre heures on a un
gendarme qui a agréé tous des six heures
en argent qui est agressé et en gros
toutes les nuits ou toutes les deux
nuits en agenda qui se fait tirer dessus
ce sont aussi des éléments qui ont été
en grande augmentation ces dernières
années
tout comme je voudrais pas tomber dans
d'une forme de sociologie de comptoir
mais tout comme on observe d'une manière
générale une augmentation des atteintes
à tout ce qui peut symboliser l'État les
règles l'économie en fait tout ce qui
est très structuré et qui à un moment
donné peut
peut être contre la philosophie de
certains qui considère que en fait il
devrait être interdit d'interdire et
concrètement on observe ça à peu près
toutes les nuits c'est souvent la nuit
et on fait le bilan tous les tous les
matins mais je pourrais revenir si vous
le souhaitez donc je vais donc
structurer mon propos en deux parties je
vais d'abord vous parler de la relation
élue gendarmerie et puis ensuite vous
dire ce que nous avons fait et ce que
nous avons en tête pour la suite pour
nous rapprocher des élus pour essayer de
faciliter ou de rendre moins compliqué
la tâche des des élus au quotidien dans
nos modalités dans le mode d'action
d'une manière générale et en particulier
ce que nous faisons avec les élus
alors pourquoi
on doit avoir un lien particulier bon je
l'ai déjà abordé on a 3100 brigades
bientôt 3300 brigades donc on a le
maillage de la fonction publique qui est
sans doute le plus le plus étendu étalé
et
en fait des 19 mères sur 20 sont en zone
gendarmerie donc l'immense majorité des
maires chez nous entre guillemets où
nous sommes chez eux
et donc ça ça explique aussi le lien
tout particulier qui doit être qui doit
être créé avec eux on a en fait 96% des
35 000 communes avec peut-être un petit
indicateur qui qui a du sens dans les
modes d'action c'est que la superficie
moyenne d'une brigade d'une communauté
de brigade c'est 300 km², c'est trois
fois Paris ou 7 fois Lyon
donc c'est aussi bien de le rappeler
parce que ça ça explique aussi qu'on
peut pas être derrière
auprès de Chuck mairie tout le temps à
chaque instant quand on est des surfaces
à couvrir le matériel j'en ai j'en ai
parlé les créations de 200 brigades nous
permettent de continuer à nous
rapprocher de la population et donc des
mères
le dans le même temps le maire est au PJ
c'est un sujet assez récurrent
maintenant le le maire on n'attend pas
le 11 c'est pas nous c'est d'une manière
générale on entend pas du maire qu'il
fasse des procédures judiciaires mais ça
veut dire aussi qu'il faut accompagner
le maire pour savoir ce qu'il peut faire
ou ne pas faire c'est aussi notre rôle
chose que l'on a commencé à faire je
pense à une application qui s'appelle
Jean délu qui est téléchargeable sur sur
les stores temps pour iPhone que pour
les téléphones Android et dans lesquels
on a de nombreux conseils à l'endroit
des mers et on offre aussi la
possibilité d'ailleurs de de chatter en
direct 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
avec un gendarme donc je l'ai testé il y
a pas longtemps sans dire qu'ils étaient
et globalement ça a marché le jour où
j'ai testé mais d'une manière générale
ça fonctionne et en fait on a on a aussi
tous ces conseils que l'on doit parce
que le maire finalement est confronté à
l'état de à l'état de sujet et ça se
décrète pas il faut
c'est compliqué sur l'environnement il y
a 16 côtes différents qui traitent de
l'environnement et on sait les sujets
que que font peser le droit de
l'environnement dans les communes et sur
les mers dans les et notamment dans les
communes les plus petites
on va y arriver on va y arriver on va
simplement baisser un peu l'activité
demander de bien parler dans le micro et
on va arriver à Saint-Brévin vous
inquiétez pas Madame de la ganterie
avant de parler de Saint-Brevin il me
semble important de savoir ce que nous
montre les maires madame après vous
pourrez mieux poser les questions
allez on laisse général s'exprimer et
ensuite on avance
je
on va y aller mais si j'ai été convié
c'est pour parler d'autre chose de
Sabrina également
donc
mais je vais aller vite puisque il
semblerait que donc concrètement
donc concrètement dans chaque brigade
l'idée d'avoir un référent élu pour que
chaque maire puisse avoir un contact
privilégié avec avec les gendarmes en
gros un numéro de portable qu'il puisse
appeler à chaque instant
les réunions je reviens pas dessus les
ceux qui ont été maire le connaissent
mais l'idée d'avoir des réunions les
plus régulières possibles
j'évoquais la l'application jean-lu qui
a été construite avec la MF on essaie de
travailler beaucoup avec la MF pour
essayer de développer un certain nombre
de de d'aide et de et pour conforter la
relation on a par exemple travaillé sur
un dispositif qui permet de détecter les
vulnérabilités Cyprien cyber pour les
communes pour les collectivités puisque
c'est quand même un gros sujet une
grosse préoccupation et en particulier
pour les petites et moyennes communes
qui sont qui sont moins entourés en fait
qui ont une structure moins puissante
que les que les grandes communes et je
terminerai dans dans les quelques
éléments que je prends pour évoquer le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
qui permet de mesurer la présence des
patrouilles de manière la densité de la
présence des patrouilles sur une durée
donnée sur une circonscription puisque
toutes les patrouilles sont
géolocalisées donc on est capable de
avoir des cartes de chaleur qui
indiquent où étaient les patrouilles sur
un mois par exemple et l'idée étant de
montrer aux élus sur leur
circonscriptions ce qu'on a constaté ont
souvent ils le savent au moins aussi
bien que nous ce que nous avions fait
pour voir où est-ce que ça ne marche pas
et pour ensuite travailler ensemble sur
ce que nous allons faire sur la période
qui suit avec des outils techniques qui
permettent de le voir ce qui permet déjà
nous de rendre des comptes aux maires
nous avons des comptes à rendre sur ce
que nous faisons et ce qui permet
également aux maires de travailler avec
ces gendarmes pour savoir comment mieux
agir dans la période qui vient et avec
des réunions de manière récurrente tous
les mois ou tous les deux mois on a 84%
de satisfaction donc on travaille pour
essayer de d'être complètement dans les
attentes des élus sur l'action de la
gendarmerie
le rôle d'accompagnement et de conseil
j'en ai parlé donc je ne reviens pas
dessus on a un certain nombre de
formations également qui ont été mises
en place et il y en a une qui peut nous
intéresser dans le cadre de Saint-Brévin
c'est la formation à la gestion de crise
en fait là aussi enfin c'est des choses
que vous savez mieux que moi le maire
est confronté en permanence à ces sujets
là avec les beaux jours on va voir des
des déplacements importants de gens du
voyage par exemple et et en fait il faut
savoir comment échanger comment discuter
savoir détecter quand la situation
commence à s'aggraver pour ne pas
physiquement en réalité un moment donné
s'exposer et savoir à quel moment
y aller avec les gendarmes
donc il y a une formation qui existe
maintenant déjà depuis quelques années
faites à l'origine par les négociateurs
du GIGN maintenant ça a été un petit peu
étendu à d'autres négociateurs on a à
peu près 30 000 élus qui ont qui ont eu
cette formation et on va continuer à la
développer ça ça permet aussi de
déconfler et d'éviter en fait c'est la
prévention et c'est quand même le
premier des effets à le premier des
effets à obtenir
et les immersions d'éluses dans les dans
les territoires j'en ai j'en ai parlé
peut-être un dernier point pour vous
dire ce que nous avons fait et les et en
fait les réflexions que nous avons pour
les pour les périodes à venir l'idée on
a commencé à le faire au moment de la de
la crise sanitaire avec les
l'opération répondent présentes nous
avions nous avions construites
l'idée de voir comment on peut à un
moment donné compenser le fait que ce
soit difficile pour un maire on avait à
l'époque par exemple gérer les masques
pour de nombreuses communes parce que le
maire était un peu seul et puis il
fallait gérer les masses et distribuer
donc on avait pris ça notre compte par
exemple mais au-delà de ça quand il y a
des plaintes quand de quand les maires
veulent un moment donné déclarer quelque
chose à la gendarmerie ils apprennent
naturel qu'on est des des voies de
collaboration particulière donc ça va
être évoqué également dans l'affaire de
Saint-Brevin c'est l'inscription sur un
fichier qui nous permet si toi qu'il y a
un appel de savoir que c'est un maire
qui appelle
ce fichier permet également lors des
patrouilles de savoir automatiquement où
sont les domiciles ou les zones
d'intérêt des élus pour que la
patrouille passe à ces endroits là
c'est aussi la possibilité d'aller
prendre une plainte à la mairie ou
n'importe où en réalité pour faire
gagner du temps au maire et le faire
dans les conditions qu'ils considéra les
plus les plus appropriés donc on l'idée
de continuer à trouver des sortes de de
voix plus rapide et surtout et ça va
être important par rapport à ce que va
dire dans un bras dans un instant pour
être sûr que les choses que nous nous
disons nous ne disons clairement et pour
que chacun comprenne réellement ce que
l'autre veut lui dire je pense que c'est
aussi un vrai sujet d'une manière
générale le monde va vite tout le monde
va vite les mers sont bousculés par
toutes les charges qui leur incombent
c'est aussi souvent le cas des gendarmes
et la première des choses c'est dur
qu'on se comprend bien
ce qui se passe la plupart du temps mais
parfois ça peut être un peu plus
compliqué et je vais la laisser relance
à Morat évoqué davantage dans le détail
ce pourquoi également nous sommes là si
en général en général vous avez la
parole
je viens je viens monsieur le monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je suis donc le général Zamora
je commande la région des Pays de la
Loire et le groupement de la
Loire-Atlantique depuis le premier
septembre 2020 et je m'apprête à quitter
mon mon commandement après trois ans
dans ses fonctions je vous remercie de
de me donner l'opportunité de m'exprimer
devant vous et ainsi de pouvoir vous
expliquer quelle a été l'action de la
gendarmerie de la loi Atlantique dans la
gestion des événements de Saint-Brevin
avant toute chose je tiens à dire dans
cette enceinte que je considère qu'on
porte atteinte à la République et
fondement même de notre société
lorsqu'on s'en prend à un élu fondement
que nous sommes en charge nous gendarmes
de défendre dire également
s'agissant des faits dont elle était
victime monsieur Morez que je les
considère lâche et révoltons je lui ai
écrit le jour de l'incendie criminel et
que tout est actuellement mis en oeuvre
pour
identifier les auteurs et les déférer
devant la justice
afin de vous exposer notre action aussi
clairement que possible je souhaite dans
un premier temps vous livrez quelques
éléments de cadrage très rapide sur la
relation gendarme mère dans le ressort
de la compagnie de Pornic puis vous
présenter le contexte local de
Saint-Brévin et enfin partager avec vous
mon appréciation de la situation
l'engagement de la gendarmerie aux côtés
de nos 198 mer de Loire-Atlantique et
une priorité de mon action au-delà de la
déclinaison dans le département de la de
la stratégie présent pour les élus et de
l'offre de services qui ont découle le
directeur général il faisait allusion il
y a quelques secondes
la relation avec les maires s'appuie sur
une sur une cinétique relationnelle
établie à plusieurs niveaux visant à
développer la relation la plus fluide
possible entre les gendarmes et les élus
de nos territoires les commandants le
commandant de compagnie de Pornic en
l'occurrence et le commandant de
communauté de brigade de Saint-Brevin
plus précisément inscrivent leur action
dans le même esprit celle d'une grande
proximité avec leur mère
vous en donnerai deux exemples dans les
semaines qui ont suivi sa prise de
fonction au premier août 2022 le
commandant de compagnie de Pornic dont
relève la commune de Saint-Brévin a
organisé une réunion au cours de
laquelle il s'est présenté à l'ensemble
des mers de sa compagnie de son ressort
en leur donnant également son numéro de
téléphone portable professionnel pour
être directement joignable les mêmes
élus disposent également des portables
de leur commandant de brigade respectifs
pour sa part lors de sa prise de
commandement à l'été 2021 le lieutenant
l'officier commandant la communauté de
brigade de Saint-Brévin rapidement
proposé à la mairie de Saint-Brevin la
tenue d'une réunion dédiée à la sécurité
sur une base bimensuelle principe qui a
été accepté par la collectivité et qui
est mise en pratique jusqu'à aujourd'hui
j'en viens au contexte de Saint-Brevin
et l'action de la gendarmerie dès
l'origine du mouvement de contestation à
la construction d'un nouveau centre
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile dans le
quartier de la pierre appelée à
Saint-Brévin une attention toute
particulière et portée par la
gendarmerie et plus particulièrement la
compagnie de Pornic à tous les aspects
que comporte ce mouvement
manifestation pro anticada tractage
sécurité du site du futur cada ou encore
protection des personnes des parties
prenantes
trois premières manifestations sont
organisées les 15 15 octobre 8 novembre
et 11 décembre 2022 elles sont
sécurisées par des dispositifs mis en
place par la compagnie de Pornic elle
donne lieu à des invectives entre
manifestants pro et anticada sont
troubles graves à l'ordre public grâce
au moyen mis en place par la gendarmerie
dès le 15 octobre 2022 le commandant de
compagnie de Pornic agit d'initiative
face au début de mobilisation constatée
en ordonnant que toutes les patrouilles
de gendarmerie opérant dans le secteur
de Saint-Brévin effectue des passages
devant le site du chantier du CADA et de
l'école de la de la pierre atelée lors
des réunions préparatoires assez
manifestations avec la mairie n'est fait
état d'aucune demande particulière en
termes de sécurité ni de menaces
quelconque
le 13 janvier des membres de
l'association des parents d'élèves de
l'école de la pierre atelée se présente
à la gendarmerie après avoir été orienté
par la mairie pour signaler l'envoi de
courrier et de mail à hanté de
l'association par un de ces membres
laissant entendre qu'il agissait en
qualité de l'ensemble des représentants
de l'association
cette association ne souhaite pas
déposer plainte mais les gendarmes de
Saint-Brévin ne se contentent pas de la
simple prise d'une main courante mais
rédige un procès-verbal de renseignement
judiciaire pour que c'est fait soient
portés à la connaissance de la procureur
de la République de de Saint-Nazaire
le 14 janvier je suis présent à
l'occasion de la de la pose de la
première pierre de la nouvelle caserne
de gendarmerie à Saint-Brévin j'échange
avec Monsieur Mourèze son qu'on aborde
ensemble voler de la sécurité lors de sa
prise de parole le mais remercie la
gendarmerie de son action pour ma part
j'exprime mes vif remerciements à la
communauté de communes pour la conduite
de ce projet immobilier le 26 janvier
une plainte de la directrice de l'école
de la pierre atelier déposée suite à une
publication sur un site internet et
l'utilisation de sa photographie qui
avait été extraite du site interne de
l'école là encore c'est la mairie qui
est à réorienté la directrice vers la
gendarmerie
le 27 janvier une réunion est organisée
en mairie de Saint-Brévin sur les sujets
de sécurité à laquelle assiste le
lieutenant commandant la communauté de
brigades et une représentation de
l'école
l'officier rappelle à cette occasion la
nécessité de rapporter son délai tout
fait lier en lien avec le projet de cada
il n'est fait il n'est pas fait état à
ce stade de menaces sur la sécurité du
maire ou de son domicile le même jour le
même jour donc 27 janvier une opération
de distribution de tracts et conduite
par les opposants au cada cette
opération sera reconduite les quatre les
premiers 4 et 10 février
et se déroulent sur fond de préparation
de la manifestation annoncée pour le 25
février la gendarmerie procède
d'initiatives au relevé des identités
des personnes présentes les autorités
administratives et judiciaires
sont informés ces opérations de contrôle
et le relevé des identités aideront les
enquêteurs dans le cadre d'une plainte
qui sera déposée par la suite le 3
février la brigade de Saint-Brévin
reçoit une nouvelle plainte déposée par
deux personnes favorables au projet de
cada dans le prolongement d'une
publication en ligne dans le cadre d'un
dépôt de plainte qui suivra également le
3 février la brigade de Saint-Brévin
reçoit une nouvelle plainte déposée par
par
deux personnes favorables au projet de
cadavres en le prolongement d'une
publication en ligne pardon dans lequel
dans laquelle leur nom est mentionné et
faisant l'objet d'un jour
le 10 février est une date importante à
la demande de l'association Aurore qui
est gérante du CADA qui s'inquiète sur
la sécurité de ces personnels une
nouvelle réunion et organisée à la
demande de cette donc de cette
association
sont présents le maire de la commune le
sous-préfet d'arrondissement et le
commandant de compagnie qui a cette
occasion a demandé un point précis des
menaces et des injures qui étaient reçus
encouragé les participants à ne pas
hésiter à déposer plainte et à rappeler
que trois enquêtes étaient déjà en cours
pour des injures et diffamations les
éventuelles suite pénales étant décidées
par le procureur de la République de
Saint-Nazaire
le 17 février 2023 la gendarmerie est
servie en copie d'un courrier du maire
daté de 15 février et adressée au
procureur de la République de Nantes
cette lettre nous dépose formellement
pas plainte mais évoque des faits qui
peuvent recevoir une qualification
pénale et donc l'ouverture l'ouverture
d'une d'une procédure avec audition de
Monsieur Morez
constatons l'erreur d'aiguillages de ce
courrier puisque la commune de
Saint-Brévin relève du tribunal
judiciaire de de Saint-Nazaire et non de
celui de Nantes le commandant de
compagnie informe directement la
procureur de la République compétent de
Saint-Nazaire qui entreprend les
démarches pour se saisir après avoir
fait le point sur les procédures déjà en
cours
et mentionné dans ce courrier le
commandant de compagnie demande à son
commandant de communauté de briades de
reprendre contact de reprendre contact
avec la mairie pour savoir si celle-ci
souhaite déposer plainte car certaines
informations
contenu dans cette lettre n'avait pas
été communiqué à la gendarmerie
auparavant y compris lors de la réunion
qui s'était déroulée seulement 5 jours
plus tôt notamment le fait
d'intimidation menace à savoir à savoir
en l'occurrence un tract
déposer dans la boîte aux lettres du
maire
tract qui était accompagné de la photo
d'un jeune mineur qui avait été enlevé
puis retrouvé assassiné quelques années
auparavant mais la mairie ne revient pas
le maire ne revient pas vers la
gendarmerie le 25 février une quatrième
manifestation organisée par le collectif
anti-cala donne lieu à des troubles à
l'ordre public elle regroupe d'un côté
des anti cadavres au nombre de 380 380
personnes dont environ 80 au profil
ultra droite en réaction 200 personnes
dont une majorité au profil ultra gauche
s'en prennent violemment aux forces de
l'ordre le dispositif de maintien de
l'ordre et dirigé par le général
commandant au second la région de
gendarmerie qui dispose de trois unités
de force mobile le maire est présent
avec son adjoint l'insécurité et ne
s'ouvre pas au général d'un sentiment
d'insécurité sur sa personne
donc jusqu'à la date du 22 mars jour de
la constatation de l'incendie criminel
aucune plainte n'est déposée en
gendarmerie par le maire ou par un de
ses adjoints
durant toute cette période et en
complément des réunions bimensuelles que
j'évoquais plutôt les échanges avec la
municipalité sont nombreux
majoritairement il faut le reconnaître
avec l'adjointe à la sécurité de la
commune soit en préparation des actions
de voie publique soit pour le suivi des
affaires courantes en outre des
directives sont données en matière de
renforcement des patrouilles de sur de
renforcement des patrouilles qui sont
au-delà du site du CADA au-delà de la
mairie au delà du domicile du maire sont
étendu au domicile du député puisque je
vous rappelle on était en pleine période
de contestation sur le projet des
retraites
le 22 mars jour de manifestation
violente dans le département de la
Loire-Atlantique la gendarmerie est
informé à 5h15 de l'incendie criminel
dont Monsieur mauvaise est victime
assurant la permanence opérationnelle
l'officiel joint commandant la compagnie
se transporte immédiatement sur le lieu
il est rejoint sur place par le
commandant de compagnie qui prendra
ensuite la direction de du pont de
Saint-Nazaire en raison des des
exactions violentes qui allaient être
commises sur l'ouvrage en matière en
matière judiciaire monsieur Morez dépose
plainte à la brigade de Saint-Brevin le
jour même pour l'instant des criminels
la direction d'enquête est rapidement
confiée à la section de recherche de
Nantes au regard de la gravité des faits
une information judiciaire est ouverte
aujourd'hui au pôle criminel du tribunal
de Nantes
en matière de sécurité publique
surveillance la compagnie de
gendarmerie de Pornic organise une
surveillance renforcée du domicile du
maire et de 5 de ses adjoints avec un
minimum de 4 passages devant son
domicile de leur domicile par période de
24 heures dans le même temps ces élus
sont inscrits avec leur accord à la base
de données SIP si pour sécurisation des
interventions et de protection qui
permet de prioriser une intervention au
regard de la sensibilité
de l'élu il est également proposé aux
maires un audit de sécurité de son
domicile par la cellule de
prévention technique de la malveillance
du groupement
le 26 mars la gendarmerie reçoit le soin
transmis du parquet de Saint-Nazaire
relatif au courrier qui avait adressé le
maire de Saint-Brévin le 15 février une
procédure est ouverte pour menace et
acte d'intimidation ce même jour la
communauté de Bria de Saint-Brévin
reçoit un autre soit transmis du parquet
concernant une plainte d'une râpe suite
au distribution de tracts en janvier et
février par des personnes donc dont
l'identité avait été relevé d'initiative
par les gendarmes le 28 mars se tient
une réunion relative à la sécurité du
maire et de ses adjoints à l'initiative
de la gendarmerie elle fait suite à
l'article de presse un article de presse
du 25 mars dans lequel monsieur Morez et
exprime son ressenti son ressenti de ne
pas avoir été entendu
en présence du maire et de plusieurs
élus le commandant de compagnie fait un
point détaillé sur les actions déjà
engagées par la gendarmerie ainsi que
sur les procédures en cours
relatives aux injures et menaces envers
les personnes liées au projet de cada
dans le cadre de ces échanges le maire
accepte accepte de remettre aux
militaires présents l'original des
lettres reçues donc le 15 février en vue
d'une entrée en procédure et d'une
plainte ultérieure le dépôt effectif de
plainte ne sera effectuée que le 17 mai
en raison de l'emploi du temps chargé du
maire malgré plusieurs relances de la
gendarmerie les actes d'enquêtes sont
pour autant déjà lancé en lien avec la
procureur de Saint-Nazaire
trois jours plus tôt trois jours plus
tôt le commandant de compagnie avait
rappelé par mail à la mairie la
procédure à suivre en cas de menace et
injures cet échange faisait suite à la
découverte par la mairie de nouveaux
messages circulant sur les réseaux et
qui se réjouissait de l'incendie des
voitures du maire il est notamment
mentionné dans son message je cite
n'hésitez surtout pas à nous demander ce
que vous jugez nécessaire pour optimiser
la protection de la commune et de ses
élus l'essentiel pour nous est vraiment
d'avancer dans une enquête difficile et
nous avons besoin du maximum
d'informations possibles bon courage
dans cette situation déplorable pour
notre vie démocratique
je ferme la citation le 29 avril une
cinquième manifestation et organisée par
le collectif anti-cala réunissant 120
opposants rejoint par 120 membres de
l'ultra droites elle donne lieu à une
contre manifestation à nouveau non
déclaré regroupant 250 membres de
l'ultra gauche nantaise et Renaise
qui s'en prennent violemment aux deux
unités de force mobiles mises à ma
disposition nécessaire l'emploi
nécessitant l'emploi de 88 grenades
lacrymogène je commande le dispositif de
la gendarmerie ce jour-là le sous
précédemment la procureur de la
République ainsi que l'adjointe la
sécurité de la commune de Saint-Brévin
sont à mes côtés tout l'après-midi ce
dernier l'agent à la sécurité ou
également conseiller départemental
me remercient de l'action des forces de
l'ordre en fin de service le 9 mai le
maire de Saint-Brévin envoie au préfet
sa demande de démission il mentionne
également dans les médias aurait été
victimes d'une agression verbale par un
opposant au cadavre deux jours plus tôt
sans que le parquet ou nous-mêmes n'en
soit informé autrement que par la presse
entre le 15 et le 18 mai monsieur Morez
dépose trois plaintes trois plaintes à
la gendarmerie de plaintes pour menaces
acte d'intimidation envers un élu une
vison les faits mentionné dans sa lettre
du 15 février
adressé au procureur de la République la
seconde pourtant sur les faits du 7 mai
la troisième plainte est prise pour
outrage à une personne pour outrage à
une personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique suite à la réception le 17 mai
d'une lettre injurieuse en provenance du
sud de la France au total monsieur Morez
a déposé 4 plaintes dont celles
relatives à l'incendie criminel dont il
a été victime
sur le sur mon appréciation de la
situation
voici
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vus de la vue de
la gendarmerie de Loire-Atlantique et de
la manière la plus détaillée les
éléments chronologiques que je
souhaitais vous communiquer sur les
événements de Saint-Brévin naturellement
naturellement je ne discute en rien le
ressenti du maire sur le manque de
soutien qu'il évoque dont celui
manifestement de la gendarmerie ce
ressenti comme les faits dont il a été
victime mon naturellement amené à
m'interroger à m'interroger sur les
signaux que nous n'avons notamment pas
perçu et sur les enseignements à tirer
des faits pour améliorer notre action
si je dresse le bilan de justement de
ces actions j'ai le sentiment que nos
gendarmes n'ont pas ménagé leurs efforts
n'ont pas ménager leurs efforts je suis
convaincu qu'ils ont affiché en
permanence une volonté d'être présent au
côté des élus de Saint-Brévin tant dans
leur quotidien au travers notamment des
liens très réguliers avec avec la mairie
l'agent à la sécurité l'adjointe aux
écoles l'adjoint à l'environnement que
dans les moments les plus les plus
tendus les plus difficiles ils se sont
montrés réactifs très investi sur tous
les événements en lien avec le projet le
CADA présence et contrôle lors des
opérations de tractage
dispositif de prévention lors d'un
conseil municipal sensible ou encore
sécurisation de la Commune à l'occasion
des manifestations de voies publiques en
matière de surveillance j'ai le
sentiment que mes gendarmes ont pris les
mesures pour renforcer leur posture
opérationnel à Saint-Brevin puis l'ont
adopté en fonction de leur perception de
la menace leur perception de la menace
elle-même liée aux informations reçues
de la mairie il convient également de
mentionner que que la pression de la
délinquance j'en reparlerai peut-être
plus tard à laquelle c'est ajouter la
mobilisation des effectifs en ordre
public ne nous laissez croyez moi peu de
marge de manœuvre à compter du 22 mars
le dispositif de surveillance a été
accentué autour du domicile du maire et
de plusieurs de ces adjoints en matière
de police judiciaire et d'investigation
les victimes ont systématiquement
systématiquement été invités à déposer
plainte et cela quelquefois à plusieurs
reprises certaines plaintes ont été
prises et diligentées sur soit transmis
du procureur de la République de
Saint-Nazaire
d'autres après orientation des victimes
par la mairie de Saint-Brévin d'autres
enfin après que la gendarmerie apprenne
des faits par voie de presse sans que la
procureur ou nous-même n'en est été
préalablement informés j'insiste sur le
fait que toutes les plaintes ont été
recueillies lorsqu'une personne se
présente à la gendarmerie pour dénoncer
des faits répréhensibles sans pour
autant vouloir déposer plainte nous
dressons un procès-verbal de
renseignements judiciaire sans nous
limiter à une simple main courante qui
resterait au sein de l'unité lorsque le
gendarme s'intéresse s'interroge pardon
sur la qualification des faits
et bien nous nous retournons
vers le procureur de la République sous
l'autorité
duquel nous nous conduisons nos
investigations
madame Madame le Procureur de
Saint-Nazaire a déjà donné des suites
pénales à certaines procédures la
majorité des autres sont attendues de
décision du parquet et les plaintes les
plus récentes sont font encore l'objet
d'investigation à la suite de l'incendie
criminel le maximum de moyens
disponibles a été mobilisé pour pour les
constatations techniques et les actes
d'enquêtes donc je l'ai dit la section
de recherche de Nantes a été engagée et
un groupe d'enquêtes créé
des interpellations ont été réalisées
au cours de la semaine dernière en dépit
de cet engagement dépit de cet
engagement cela n'a manifestement pas
suffi
et m'amène nécessairement à cette
question qu'aurions nous pu faire de
mieux il m'apparaît clairement que nous
n'avons pas pris la mesure du désarroi
du maire notamment lors de la réunion du
10 février organisé en présence du
sous-préfet d'arrondissement et du
commandant de compagnie
cette réunion où a été posée entre
autres la question de ceux qui
constituent une infraction pénale et de
ceux qui relèvent de la liberté
d'expression me semble être à l'origine
d'une véritable incompréhension entre le
maire et l'autorité publique alors que
le maire a conclu qu'on le dissuadait de
déposer plainte au motif justement de la
liberté d'expression le commandant de
compagnie lui listé de son côté
les les infractions
viser par le code pénal et notamment les
injures diffamation outrage intimidation
agression physique en indiquant que
pourrait poursuivi et doivent être
caractérisés au sens du code de
procédure pénale
alors il me paraît évident il me paraît
évident que ce message n'est pas bien
passé
car certainement trop technique
par rapport à une victime qui se sentait
démunie isolées et on attendent surtout
de répondre de réponse immédiate pour
être rassuré
c'est naturellement c'est naturellement
regret un regret qui fait écho au
sentiment d'échec collectif mentionné
dans cette salle par Monsieur le Préfet
de région il y a il y a quelques
quelques semaines de cela ce regret est
d'autant plus fort que les efforts
déployés par mes gendarmes je leur redis
ont été conséquents et continueront de
l'être
dans ce contexte
le contact avec la nouvelle mère de
Saint-Brevin et ses gendarmes me semble
parfaitement établie je suis satisfait
de la de la fréquence des échanges en
présentiel ou au téléphone qu'ils ont
ensemble directement à l'initiative de
l'un comme de l'autre je vous remercie
de votre attention merci mon général je
vais donner la parole maintenant un
certain nombre de collègues qui l'ont
demandé et dans l'ordre suivant Monsieur
Alain Marc madame Marie Mercier monsieur
Dany boiteblée monsieur hussienne
Bourgey mesdames Brigitte l'herbier pour
les premiers inscrits monsieur Marc
merci Président Monsieur les généraux
chers collègues les relations que nous
avons sur le terrain avec la gendarmerie
sont souvent très bons la gendarmerie
sait faire pour
dans ces relations avec avec les élus
nous sommes souvent invités à éviter le
brigade à participer à des actions nous
avons nous-mêmes les
capable des commandes de compagnie
de commande d'un groupement et je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose
à matière de menaces aux élus je vais
juste reprendre
un petit fait qui s'est qui a eu lieu un
Aveyron il a fallu comme mère porte 6
fois pleines pour que la dernière
plainte soit prise en considération sans
doute l'actualité n'y était le pas pour
rien alors ce n'est pas vous qui êtes en
cause mesdames Messieurs les gendarmes
mais ne faudrait-il pas alors je sais
que dans notre département ça se passe
peut-être un peu mieux j’en ai échangé
avec François Noel buffet sur ce sujet
que l'autorité judiciaire soit plus
proche des élus alors si une histoire de
formation au niveau de l'École nationale
de la magistrature je crois qu'on n'a
pas complètement pris la mesure de ce
que représenter les élus sur le
territoire et l'ours est certains
procureurs
classe sont ensuite des plaintes et l'AS
qui mériteraient d'être pris autrement
en considération et on éviterait quand
il a fallu six ou comme mère porte 6
fois pleines parce que le contexte est
celui sans doute de Saint-Brevin etc et
que la justice ensuite se prononce avec
des condamnations ça en dit long sur ce
qu'il vous vous n'êtes pas en cause mais
je crois qu'il faut une meilleure
relation entre les procureurs et les
élus on voit les procureurs lors des
saintes Geneviève c'est très bien il y a
le discours de temps en temps on les
appelle en leur disant les avancées
qu'on peut avoir réalisé nous d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de la commission des lois
et au niveau du PLF etc ce qui peut
avoir lieu mais ça va pas plus loin et
je crois qu'il y a un véritable problème
soit dans la formation soit dans la
relation actuelle que l'on doit avoir me
semble-t-il pour que tout fonctionne
bien au niveau de la société entre
l'autorité judiciaire et les élus merci
chers collègues madame Marie Mercier
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour vos exposés nous
connaissons les liens étroits qu'il
existe sur les terrains entre nos
gendarmes et les élus général Rodriguez
je vous avais interrogé il y a trois ans
déjà sur l'augmentation des violences
qu'elles soient intrafamiliales
vis-à-vis des élus vis-à-vis des
pompiers etc je vous avais demandé quel
était votre sentiment je vous avais
demandé pouvez-vous de façon très
synthétique nous dire ce qui à votre
sens avait changé et vous nous aviez
répondu ce qui a changé c'est le rapport
à la règle si je vous repose la question
aujourd'hui générale est-ce que vous
allez me répondre la même chose je pense
que peut-être oui et à ce moment-là que
préconisez-vous pour stopper cette
escalade dangereuse et les rapports dans
notre société
merci Madame merci Monsieur Dany
watteblé merci Monsieur Merci monsieur
jennereau c'est vrai que depuis des
années on a pu le rapport de la peur du
gendarme et du maire donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec un maire qui va sur le
terrain problème voisinage problème de
bruit gens du voyage
ainsi terre rodéo et effectivement qu'on
a dit très bien à la marque c'est le
rapport justement avec la justice
puisque je pense que le trahi est fait
de base il y a une plainte qu'il est
posée et bien souvent elle met un
certain délai
et bien souvent être trop tardivement et
je pense qu'il faut être pour faire un
peu comment on fait un peu le flagrant
délit parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en
trop total décalage j'aurais qu'un petit
exemple à donner et j'ai un collègue
mère qui a 1400000 euros dans une
gendarmerie enfin dans une police
municipale il a un rodéo il poursuit le
l'auteur du rodéo il rattrape ils
prennent le l'engin il le met dans la
mairie et puis la personne passe en
comparution rappelle à la loi et le
procureur dit à ce maire il faut rendre
l'engin
donc se met renvoyer sa démission
préférée
parce qu'il se trouvait que son autorité
un peu bafouer puisque l'engin
normalement on a voté une voix qui peut
être détruit et en plus il passe à BFM
TV et qu'est-ce qui se passe derrière
c'est le même la même personnel sur ce
scooter qui s'amuse à refaire rodéo
voilà un petit peu le comment un maire
peut être déçu et c'est comme ça
constamment donc je pense plutôt c'est
du côté de la Justice de la relation
comme ça très bien dit avec le procureur
qui ont total décalé je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment avoir un flagrant
délit d'agression sur un maire ou de
fées et traiter dans la rapidité au
moins sur ça servir d'exemple
merci Monsieur Wate la parole est à
Monsieur scène Borgi merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
généraux
ne nous méprenons pas ni les uns ni les
autres je crois qu'ici vous avez
beaucoup d'alliés la gendarmerie
nationale a beaucoup d'alliés et
beaucoup de défenseurs donc ce n'est pas
une audition dans lesquelles nous
serions en train d'incriminer la
gendarmerie nationale mais au contraire
essayer de comprendre ce qui a
dysfonctionné parce que chacun et
chacune d'entre nous pourraient citer
des dizaines et des dizaines d'exemples
qui illustrent l'excellente relation qui
existe sur le terrain entre les élus
nationaux les élus locaux et la
gendarmerie pour ma part je pourrais
vous parler longuement des relations que
j'entre cas avec le général Silva Laniel
dans l'Hérault ce n'est pas le sujet le
sujet qui nous réunit aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui s'est passé à Saint-Brévin et
nous avons tous et toutes mesuré le
désarroi la détresse du maire des
missionnaire de Saint-Brevin nous avons
ressenti pour lui et avec lui un
sentiment d'injustice c'est ce qui nous
a amené les uns et les autres à nous
intéresser à cette affaire et c'est
ainsi que j'ai pu découvrir la
mobilisation qui avait été la vôtre
mobilisation en termes d'effectif
puisque effectivement vous n'avez pas
les idées sur les moyens lors de la
manifestation du 15 décembre il y avait
pas moins de 60 gendarmes mobilisés pour
sécuriser les deux rassemblements qui
avaient lieu à Saint-Brévin donc réunir
60 gendarmes dans une commune comme
Saint-Brevin sa témoigne bien de la
prise en compte de la gravité de la
situation mais je suis remonté un peu
plus
en avant dans le temps et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était lorsque le
gouvernement en 2016 avait décidé de
démanteler la jungle de Calais que les
premiers réfugiés étaient arrivés à
Saint-Brevin et lorsque ces réfugiés
étaient arrivés à Saint-Brevin il y
avait un événement que j'ai découvert et
dont personne n'a parlé jusqu'à présent
ce sont ces tirs à balles réelles contre
les murs
du centre d'accueil de Saint-Brevin donc
un individu dont l'identité n'a jamais
été établie
attiré sur le les locaux qui devaient
accueillir ces 70
réfugiés ou demandeurs d'asile ou
appelons comme on veut et cette affaire
là en fait n'a pas eu de suite et je
trouve pour ma part surprenante que des
tirs à balles réel sur un équipement
comme celui-ci n'est pas connu de
développement en tout cas n'est pas été
évoqué jusqu'à présent la seconde chose
qui m'a
interpellé dans cette histoire c'est les
plaintes qui ont été déposées le 3
février par Monsieur Philippe Croze et
son premier vice-président Philippe
Croze étant le président de
l'association des brevinois attentifs et
solidaires donc un monsieur de 73 ans
qui se décide à déposer plainte un
retraité de la fonction publique au
fonctionnaire qui préside cette
association parce qu'il a été sollicité
pour accompagner initialement entre 2016
et 2017 les 70 personnes arrivées à
Saint-Brévin dans leur démarche lorsque
ils sont partis il y en avait plus
ils ont fait autre chose des activités
culturelles et ce monsieur se retrouve
avec son nom son adresse son identité
son numéro de téléphone publiés sur les
réseaux sociaux comme pour le maire et
comme pour un certain nombre d'élus il
dépose plainte avec son vice-président
le 3 février et effectivement le 10
février comme vous l'avez tout à l'heure
et indiqué mon Général Zamora sur la
réunion qui a eu lieu à la demande de
l'association Aurore à laquelle
participe le sous-préfet le maire et
vous-même et en tout cas vous
représentant c'est à ce moment là que le
sous-préfet découvre l'existence de ces
deux plaintes en disant mais vous me
parlez d'un contexte tendu et grave je
ne suis pas au courant le dépôt de
plainte et donc c'est à ce moment-là que
Monsieur Croze et son vice-président
donne les plaintes aux sous-préfet une
semaine après les avoir déposés et dans
la foulée c'est à cette occasion là que
le maire de Saint-Brévin de l'époque dit
mais il y a une situation qui est un peu
quand même inquiétante injurieuse et là
il lui a répondu c'est malheureux c'est
regrettable mais c'est l'expression de
la démocratie sachez qu'il nous dit et
pour moi ça c'est quelque chose que je
ne peux pas entendre l'expression la
démocratie c'est descendre sur la voie
publique manifester contester mais
lorsqu'on est maire lorsqu'on est élu
qu'on est victime de du fait de subir
des intrusions lors du conseil municipal
parce que j'ai découvert que des gens
rentraient dans la salle du conseil
municipal mettez des tracts injurieux
sur les bancs des élus ça s'est passé
mais ça s'est passé avant-hier je ne
sais pas si vous le savez mes collègues
mais avant-hier il y avait un conseil
municipal à Saint-Brevin avec la
nouvelle mer il y avait une vingtaine de
personnes qui sont venues au conseil
municipal donc dès lors qu'on est dans
cette posture là il me semble qu'il y a
un problème qui aurait dû peut-être
mobiliser un peu plus je vais conclure
en vous disant on vous interrogeant
monsieur
général zambora sur la les suites qui
ont été donnés dans certaines procédures
vous nous dites par le parquet de
Saint-Nazaire puisque c'est suite ont
été donnés pouvez-vous nous indiquer de
quelle nature il s'agit pour quelle
procédure et combien de procédures sont
encore aujourd'hui en cours
d'instruction merci Monsieur Bourgi
Madame Brigitte l'herbier puis madame
cuerman
monsieur le président général Rodriguez
général Zamora
vous constatations montées de violence
qui se développe et qui se remplissent
notre pays
on le constate tous
on constate un sentiment de frustration
des habitants dès que une décision de
leur convient pas vous l'avez rappelé et
c'est effectivement ce qu'on constate
toutes les jours
j'ai été adjointe à la sécurité de
Tourcoing une grande ville de 100.000
habitants et on faisait des cellules de
veille donc c'est des zones commissariat
jeune police on faisait des cellules de
veille tous les vendredis matin et
des constatations de ce genre constater
tous les vendredis je pense que
face à ces violences on avait
de quoi réagir on avait de quoi réagir
quand on connaissait bien ce qui allait
développer cette violence
on y arrivait pas forcément les rodéo
etc on y arrivait pas forcément mais on
avait une connaissance de l'évolution de
la situation
dans le cas de Saint-Brevin je pense que
la décision ayant été prise en amont
nationalement on va dire puisque c'est
comme ça qui nous l'a présenté Monsieur
le Maire
j'aurais voulu savoir si des relations
en amont justement se mettent en place
dès que des décisions avec la préfecture
notamment gendarmerie police avec la
préfecture
quand des décisions justement très
importantes vont être prises en amont
avant même que ça n'arrive prenons
l'exemple nous avons voté la
construction de prison nous avons voté
des décisions concernant l'immigration
on va encore
l'évoquer sur les gens du voyage etc
tout ça on le sait avant pratiquement
que le maire ne soit vraiment concerné
alors moi ce qui m'est ce que je
souhaiterais et je pense que ça doit se
faire comme ça c'est que des décisions
soient prises en amont gendarmerie et
police et
préfecture avant que ça n'arrive sur le
terrain parce que là en l'occurrence
dans l'histoire du maire de Saint-Brevin
c'était des réactions personnelles
vis-à-vis du maire on a tout reporté sur
le maire alors que c'est un ensemble
d'institutions qui avaient été concerné
en amont
merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur
les jeunes
tours d'autres présentations pour votre
retour et compris très exhaustif des
différents faits
dire comme on fait à mes collègues
précédemment que ne s'agit je crois
nullement de remettre en cause et en
question le fonctionnement au quotidien
qui se déroule bien dans dans la plupart
des cas entre les forces de gendarmerie
les élus locaux la population même plus
largement et et les parlementaires je
crois qu'au contraire il s'agit vraiment
ici de finalement de finir de comprendre
ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
et au-delà d'ailleurs de trouver des
coupables ou
des personnes qui seraient les seules
responsables de ce dysfonctionnement
comment peut-être est-ce que d'ailleurs
collectivement quelque chose n'a pas
fonctionné et nous en sommes arrivés là
si tantôt qu'on le puisse parce que je
crois qu'il est toujours important à ce
moment-là de rappeler que le risque zéro
n'existe pas
qui nous convient de le contenir le plus
possible mais mais non pas nous n'avons
pas les moyens de l'empêcher est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas
alors au regard de l'expérience de
sabrevin mais plus largement de d'autres
remontées que vous pouvez avoir et
d'autres collègues qui ont déjà fait
référence aujourd'hui finalement un
manque de perception tant de la part des
élus que des gendarmes qui peuvent
parfois enregistrer les plaintes ou main
courante de la d'une nouvelle difficulté
dans la société qui fait que de ce qui
était précédemment une menace aussi
désagréable dangereuse et inacceptables
soient-elles des réalités aujourd'hui de
passage à l'acte de plus en plus
fréquent et et quand passage à la Tilia
de plus en plus violent je j'entends ce
que vous avez dit et pour avoir eu un
certain nombre de vues qui ont été
confrontés dans des faits bien moins
graves combien de fois m'ont-ils dit oui
mais j'ai pas le temps je passerai la
semaine prochaine est-ce qu'il y a un
moment donné j'ai envie de dire là du
côté des élus un accompagnement et vous
avez je crois aussi ce rôle là de donner
à voir que c'est
non pas dans l'immédiateté mais qu'à le
temps joue aussi en leur faveur dans la
capacité à agir est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
non plus parce que on peut avoir
d'autres cas et la question n'est pas de
stigmatisée telle ou telle parfois dans
dans les différentes personnes présentes
une façon de se dire oui on verra demain
et ce n'est peut-être pas la priorité
voilà je vais le dire ainsi mais voilà
et je ferai un dernier parallèle c'est
que il me semble qu'il y a quelques
années tout de même en tout cas je le
regarde au niveau du département de la
Loire mais de très gros efforts de très
gros efforts pardon étaient faits dans
la formation notamment dans les
gendarmes et c'était aussi en zone
police surtout ce qui concerne les
violences faites aux femmes les
violences familiales sur des temps de
formation mais aussi de de vigilance
auprès des différents gendarmes pour
prendre en compte pour prendre la mesure
du réel parfois des non-dits d'ailleurs
et ainsi mieux entendre
recevoir
la plainte de la victime est-ce qu'il
n'y aurait pas parce qu'on le voit à
travers le cas extrême de Saint-Brevin
mais mais sur plein d'autres je l'ai
déjà dit à peut-être avoir une capacité
à mieux travailler mieux former pour
mieux anticiper et que vous soyez aussi
parfois en capacité de mieux déceler un
certain nombre de menaces qui peuvent
devenir effectivement profondément
dangereuses pour les individus élus en
l'occurrence je remercie
d'Arnaud oui merci monsieur le Président
si les généraux très brièvement bien sûr
m'associer à l'ensemble des collègues
qui ont salué comme il se doit le
travail et la proximité que vous
entretenez sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires avec avec les élus moi
j'avais deux interrogations la première
au regard finalement et après les
différentes auditions que nous avons eu
notamment
du préfet
de départements sous préfet de vous-même
et du maire bien évidemment le sentiment
qu'il y a quelque chose effectivement
qui va bien au-delà des simples faits
que vous avez à juste titre rappelé qui
tient effectivement du sentiment parfois
de détresse et d'isolement du maire et
des élus dans ces moments-là et qu'il
est bien évidemment difficile de traiter
simplement
dire que parfois on a on a le sentiment
qu'il serait bon de réinterroger le
trium vira entre le préfet procureur et
la gendarmerie notamment en matière de
concordance des des temps pour faire
écho un peu à ce que disait ma collègue
Brigitte l'herbier et deuxième point moi
ce qui m'a ce qui m'a un peu interpellé
dans cette affaire c'est le sentiment
que certains signaux qu'on pourrait
qualifier de faible alors que
ils sont pour nous forts je pense
notamment à l'évocation qui j'ai fait le
maire de Saint-Brevin sur certains
tracts particulièrement odieux qui avait
été délivré dans dans des boîtes aux
lettres on a eu le sentiment que ces
signaux-là n'avaient peut-être pas eu
l'écho la résonance qu'il laissait
malheureusement après âgées des suites
à l'instar de celles qu'on a mal
malheureusement connu donc voilà c'était
pour avoir un peu votre sentiment aussi
sur ces sujets là je vous remercie en
tout cas merci Monsieur d'Arnaud et bien
vous avez messieurs la parole dans
l'ordre que vous souhaiterez
Rodriguez merci monsieur le Président je
vais prendre ceux qui m'incombent et
puis je laisserai Roland évoquer les
sujets brevinois je précise que j'ai
commandé la compagnie de Pornic il y a
très longtemps je connais parfaitement
la zone d'ailleurs il y a quelques élus
qui sont encore en place donc c'est
c'est aussi quelque chose qui m'a touché
parce que moi j'avais inauguré la
précédente brigade de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins et j'y étais
retourné il y a peu de temps pour une
graine brigade à Sainte-Pazanne plus
précisément
s'agissant des questions monsieur saint
Jean-Marc sur le les menaces aux élus
les six plaintes pour une prise en
compte et
le sujet la proximité et la relation
avec l'autorité judiciaire alors je suis
pas le mieux passé pour en parler mais
au fond vous avez raison il faut qu'il y
ait vraiment une
un vrai lien après
enfin je crois que le Garde des Sceaux a
été entendu mais
c'est pas forcément intuitif là le
pour revenir un petit peu à la zone
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins c'est au sud de la
Loire
Saint-Nazaire là où il y a le procureur
c'est au nord de la Loire et il y a une
vraie culture Sud Loire Nord Loire dans
dans le département de Loire-Atlantique
mais au fond vous avez raison on n'est
jamais trop proche de toute façon et
nous on peut être le bon trait d'union
et en fait c'est un peu au final le le
sujet qui se pose mais j'y reviendrai à
la faveur d'autres réponses c'est qu'on
doit mieux jouer ce rôle de trait
d'union nous on est décideurs de rien on
parlait trium vira procureur préfet
gendarmerie nous on est le trait d'union
alors je me défonce pas mais parce que
on a ce rôle à jouer de Lyon entre les
uns les autres et on l'a sans doute pas
suffisamment bien fait là mais je j'y
reviendrai en tout cas au fond je suis
d'accord je rebondis simplement sur les
six plaintes pour une parce que ça
renvoie à ce que les gendarmes ont fait
et sur la le travail d'accompagnement
qui est nécessaire en fait une plainte
on pourrait tout à fait alors la
solution simple pour le gendarme c'est
de prendre la plainte d'envoyer la
plainte et puis après de dire bah c'est
pas notre faute c'est la faute du prank
et en réalité je considère qu'on joue
pas notre rôle parce qu'effectivement la
question était posée on a un rôle
d'accompagnement mais ça veut dire que
il faut dire les choses telles que le
gendarme les pense en disant précisément
là il y aura pas de poursuite parce que
ce fait là il sera pas interprété dans
dans comme a fait qui caractérise
l'infraction où là il y a pas
d'infraction
et ceci dans notre affaire là on parle
de on évoque des signaux faibles on
évoque mais la vraie difficulté c'est
traduire ça on regarde ce que le code
pénal prévoit et gendarme il doit dire
les choses parce que si il se contente
d'envoyer la plainte et de faire le
facteur en fait de faire le procédurier
le facteur à mon avis il est pas dans
son rôle alors qu'en réalité
il jouerait ce rôle là on pourrait rien
lui reprocher formellement mais c'est
pas c'est pas ce service là qu'on doit
rendre aux élus donc en tout cas oui
pour votre réponse de toute façon on
n'est jamais trop proche les uns les
autres et je pense oui que
je pense aussi pour être honnête qu'à la
faveur de de tout ce qui se dit sur le
le l'insécurité des élus plus forte
aujourd'hui qu'hier beaucoup de
procureurs se sont saisis de ces sujets
là et comme beaucoup de gendarmes mais
mais il faut que 100% des procureurs des
gendarmes des préfets il faut que tout
le monde soit complètement aligné je
peux vraiment être d'accord
Mercier sur le sujet du rapport à la
règle ouais je vous répondrai toujours
la même chose j'ajouterai que on a un
cumul des crises ces derniers temps qui
ajoute encore à la difficulté les
personnes à la faveur de la notamment la
crise sanitaire les personnes les plus
fragiles sont encore plus fragiles
qu'avant et on le voit dans les
territoires territoires qui étaient déjà
assez malmené parce que la France des
ronds ce sont ces territoires-là c'est
c'est souvent nos territoires à nous
avec des gens qui se trouvent comme
déclassés par rapport aux habitants des
grandes villes et c'est le vrai sujet et
ce rapport à la règle dès lors qu'on
considère qu'on n'est pas traité
équitablement ça ça pose ça pose
question puisque ça légitime le fait
d'enfreindre la règle et aujourd'hui on
a des manifestations de ceux de cette
nature là manifestation au sens large
pas la manif dans la rue qui démontre
qui démontre cela et dans les
Territoires c'est souvent ce que la
population dit au gendarmes et a forturé
aux élus donc oui mais les crises ne
nous ont pas aidé et comment on peut là
je veux pas mêler au-dessus de ma
condition mais comment on peut résister
par rapport à cela c'est c'est sur les
valeurs de la République que chacun
porte et qui doit concerner tout le
monde dès le plus premier des âges avec
un rôle qui que tout le monde doit
partager mais là je suis pas le plus
compétent pour en parler mais on doit
aussi nous prendre notre part et
notamment dans ce rôle d'accompagnement
qui doit aller au-delà de la simple
mission du gendarme
sur les rapports en justice
les délais de procédure oui alors moi ce
que je prends moi pour mon compte c'est
qu'il faut qu'on s'assure nous que les
procédures on les fait rapidement alors
c'est aussi tout le sens de aller
prendre la plainte aller voir le maire
pour pour prendre la place à lui la cité
à déposer plainte je suis également
d'accord sur ce qui a été dit il faut le
faire il faut il faut lacter et parfois
on dit ben on verra plus tard mais non
il faut pas avoir plus tard là aussi on
a un rôle à jouer qui est pas forcément
le rôle qui était écrit
traditionnellement mais c'est
l'accompagnement que l'on doit au maire
donc là aussi je suis complètement
d'accord et de notre côté il faut qu'on
fasse le nécessaire pour que la
procédure soit bien rédigée et pour
qu'elle soit faite le plus vite possible
et ce qui permet de traiter en flagrance
la plupart du temps et sur des tas de
fait les gens du voyage c'est tous les
faits il faut qu'on soit capable de
faire vite ce qui est pas tous les jours
simple parce que les les contraintes
parfois sont compliquées pour tout le
monde mais en tout cas oui c'est le
c'est l'objectif que l'on doit que l'on
doit atteindre donc je suis parfaitement
d'accord également
sur le les signes faibles monsieur
sénateur est sur le notamment les tirs
en 2016 ça fait 7 ans alors certes une
fois qu'on a vu le film c'est plus
facile de de voir où à un moment donné
il y a quelque chose qui nous aura
échappé mais la vie continue tout le
temps il y a les ces tracts qui sont
plus récents qui après coup sans doute
on se dit qu'on aurait dû davantage de
prendre en compte c'est aussi on lira ce
que vous allez ce que vous allez écrire
parce que ça va nous servir nous à
améliorer la réponse encore une fois
c'est vrai qu'après coup on se rend
compte que sur ces sujets là on aurait
dû percevoir les choses de meilleure
manière après j'ajoute que pour bien
percevoir les choses il faut que
l'émetteur et le récepteur se parlent
souvent
c'est aussi important moi ce que je
retiens c'est que les gendarmes et
surtout un rapport avec l'adjoint à la
sécurité
donc je sais pas pourquoi et c'est passé
pas le mais
les mers et les maires que je vois
notamment au salon des mers j'en croise
beaucoup il faut qu'il nous récollection
entre les maires et les commandements
et si
et si c'est de notre fait il faut qu'on
y veille et qu'on rectifie les choses
très vite donc on va travailler
là-dessus on va regarder là-dessus on va
je vais demander également aux échelons
locaux de regarder si effectivement on a
on a un vrai une vraie relation et aux
endroits où la relation n'est pas bonne
il faut qu'on y travaille avec le maire
avec la municipalité pour que les parce
que c'est le meilleur moyen de bien
comprendre et je pense que là aussi à un
moment donné on sait pas tout à fait
compris c'est ce que Roland zamaha
disait tout à l'heure lors de cette
réunion du 10
manifestement tout le monde parlait pas
la même langue ou même langage il y a
des choses qui ont été dites qui ont pas
été
en tout cas là aussi je peux je ne peux
qu'être d'accord nous on l'idée vraiment
de travailler dessus est-ce qu'il y a un
travail en amont avec la préfecture avec
alors en fait oui c'est sur à peu près
tous les sujets c'est ce que c'est ce
qui est fait pardon
oui oui alors mais on prend en principe
il a la relation est constante les
préfets les sous préfets voient les
responsables des services police
gendarmerie et autres pour justement
anticiper et prévoir pour faire en sorte
que les choses se passent le mieux
possible
il faut rien rater donc il faut aussi
qu'on y travaille et puis là aussi la
connexion du commandant de la
gendarmerie locale qui soit le
commandant de compagnie aux commandes
brigade et du maire elle est vitale pour
que ça marche
c'est ce sont des voies de progrès qui
sont qui sont nécessaires je laisserai
pour la partie de Saint-Brévin Roland
des bocquets
le le donc la relation sur le dépôt de
plâtre et on verra demain j'en ai parlé
mais je suis d'accord avec vous je vous
le disais sur la formation
en forme jamais trop
c'est vrai que sur les violences
intrafamiliales il y avait un gros
travail de formation pour pour mieux
accueillir les victimes
l'idée c'est qu'on est aussi dans la
relation avec les maires que le public
des maires entre guillemets soit un
public qui soit privilégié c'est le sens
de l'inscription sur les bases de
données c'est le sens de du traitement
particulier si un des potes plainte donc
il faut il faut qu'on le regarde on a on
a des élus qui interviennent dans la
formation de nos de nos gendarmes de nos
officiers de relève gendarmes et élève
officiers il faut qu'on regarde si ça
suffit mais les élus doivent avoir un
contact et un canal un peu particulier
on regarde de ce qu'il représente et de
la relation que nous avons sachant que
encore une fois ils sont tous en
première ligne avec les gendarmes à
leurs côtés
donc oui j'ai parlé de sujets
concordance du temps des temps préfet
procureur gendarmes donc à nous nous
vraiment de jouer pleinement notre rôle
et sur les signaux faibles les tracts
effectivement après coup on aurait dû
les voir autrement et
il faut qu'on soit meilleur là-dessus
également je vais laisser mon rêve ok
les questions posées sur Saint-Brevin
bien sur le sénateur je vais commencer
par le bas de question et les éléments
techniques que que vous soulevez sur le
conseil municipal qui s'est qui s'est
tenu il y a il y a deux jours de cela il
se trouve que j'avais
il se trouve que ce jour-là j'étais à
Saint-Brevin et que j'ai je me suis
rendu en mairie pour saluer
madame Pacaud la mère et
en lui réaffirmant qu'on serait là pour
elle quand on serait là pour elle et
notamment qu'on allait sécuriser
le conseil municipal qui s'est tenu en
soirée et auquel effectivement était
présent des opposants
à ce fin des opposants appartenant à ce
collectif Brévinois de
anticada voilà vous donnez le volume de
11 pour la gendarmerie et le
renseignement territorial ou non vous
donnez le chiffre de 20 pour la
gendarmerie et le renseignement
territorial de mémoire ils étaient 11
voilà ils ont assisté calmement au
conseil municipal d'après mes
informations ils n'ont rien dit il faut
dire que autour il y avait quand même
pas mal de pas mal de gendarmes ça
aurait été osé
osé oser de de vraiment oser de
perturber la séance alors effectivement
à l'issue du conseil municipal il y a eu
des échanges vifs avec l'équipe
municipale nous étions présents
et nous avons raccompagné la mère à son
domicile pour qu'elle se sente
complètement en sécurité et Madame Paco
a remercié à remercier les gendarmes
je note aussi que
à l'occasion
de son élection dans le fauteuil de mer
de mémoire et c'était le 9 le 9 juin
nous étions présents et nous avions
refoulé un des individus quelques
individus ultra-droits qui qui était qui
s'était rendu à Saint-Brevin
manifestement pour perturber la tenue du
conseil nous les avons donc repoussés
pour que le conseil et l'élection de la
mer se déroulent dans les meilleures
conditions sans qu'on puisse retenir une
quelconque qualification pénale à cette
présence
voilà
s'agissons s'agissant des suites pénales
donnés je suis un peu ennuyé ennuyé
parce que
[Musique]
je ne peux véritablement pas m'exprimer
au nom de l'autorité judiciaire ce que
je sais et je suis bien placé pour le
savoir c'est que aussi bien le procureur
de la République de Nantes que la
procureur de la République de
Saint-Nazaire suivent personnellement et
individuellement toutes les procédures
en lien avec une agression d'élus je
peux vous je peux vous l'assurer
pour ne parler que de Saint-Brevin
madame la procureur a organisé au moins
deux ou trois réunions avec le
commandant de compagnie
pour aborder le sujet des procédures des
suites qui pourraient être donnés et je
note que hier matin
Madame le Procureur a reçu madame Pacaud
et le commandant de compagnie pour
évoquer les plaintes qui ont été
déposées par par la mère de
par la mère de Saint-Brevin voilà en
l'état de mes informations une procédure
a été classée sans suite la majorité des
autres sont en attente de décision et
les plus récentes font sont en cours
d'investigation
sur
sur le volet madame sénatrice où
j'évoquais le de mémoire le volet
accompagnement accompagnement
accompagnement aux formations et puis
dans la suite des propos du directeur
général je voulais je voulais je tenais
à vous dire que
170 m et adjoints en Loire-Atlantique
ont été formés
au travers de ce module
intitulé gestion pacifique des
incivilités aux élus
délivrée par des négociateurs de la
gendarmerie eux-mêmes formés par par le
GIGN une initiative que nous avons pris
que nous avons élargi en
Loire-Atlantique récemment aux agents
d'accueil des collectivités
territoriales qui sont également
menacées et de la fonction hospitalière
en commençant par Nantes
j'en profite aussi pour dire que au-delà
des plaintes
des plaintes d'élus les autres
catégories de de personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique sont également
victimes d'agression
je me permets de vous le dire ainsi à
titre à titre d'exemple entre 2021 et
2022 le nombre de gendarmes victimes a
augmenté de 88%
88% en 2022 j'ai eu
493 gendarmes blessés et ou trajet un
gendarme qui sont systématiquement
invités à déposer plainte tout comme
leurs élus tout comme leurs élus voilà
formation je pourrais mais c'était pas
le sujet de mon intervention puisque
j'étais centré sur Saint-Brevin j'aurais
pu vous parler d'autres initiatives
qu'on mène localement notamment ce que
j'appelle ces tickets embarquement
tickets embarquement où on invite les
maires à venir à Nantes visiter le
centre opérationnel de la gendarmerie
pour pour qu'ils appréhendent davantage
notre notre service au quotidien on leur
parle aussi notamment de ce de ce
fichier sécurisation des des
interventions et de protection
et puis ce ticket embarquement comprend
un deuxième volet celui proprement dit
de l'embarquement où on invite les
maires à monter nos dans à bord de nos
véhicules et de nous suivre toute une
partie d'une patrouille pour pour
prendre conscience du service de la
gendarmerie quelques semaines il y a
quelques semaines de cela encore je
recevais un maire d'une petite commune
qui était accompagnée de son adjoint de
sécurité d'un policier municipal au
centre opérationnel de Nantes pour lui
montrer comment comment nos fonctions
comment nous fonctionnions parce que je
suis très attaché aux principes de
redevabilité au rôle de principe de la
vie sur les signaux faibles monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur vous est vous vous
mentionnez les signaux faibles alors
effectivement en l'absence de menaces
directes en la séance de menace directe
il existait des signaux faibles mais ces
signaux faibles étaient contenus dans
cette lettre du 15 février
ou manifestement monsieur Morez a eu
besoin suite à cette réunion 5 jours
plus tôt qui s'est mal déroulé le 10
février monsieur Morez a eu besoin
d'expliquer par écrit sur deux pages à
son ressenti vous avez parlé d'isolement
du sentiment d'isolement des mers je
l'entends souvent les meilleurs qui se
sentent démunis et ici il est
certainement utile de rappeler que la
gendarmerie de la Loire-Atlantique c'est
44 points d'accueil du public et donc
c'est un le gendarme et le représentant
de proximité de l'État dans dans le
territoire donc ces signaux faibles
c'était en l'occurrence dans ces deux
pages dans ces deux pages c'est de ces
deux missives qu'il avait reçu dans sa
boîte aux lettres avec notamment une
particulièrement infâme avec des photos
de cet enfant
et cet enfant qui avait été enlevé
peut-être certains d'entre vous certains
d'entre vous sont
sans souviennent donc au-delà de
la non prise en compte de ces signaux
faibles il y a évidemment ce sentiment
de désarroi du maire
s'agissons s'agissant enfin de
de la relation entre émetteur et
récepteur
général
Rodriguez faisait faisait allusion cette
connexion n'a pas fonctionné à
Saint-Brevin elle n'a pas fonctionné la
fonctionné à sens unique la fonctionné
sens unique du commandant de compagnie
vers le maire les relations entre les
deux étaient systématiquement
du côté du commandant de compagnie vers
le maire selon ce que mement dit le
commandant de compagnie et cette
situation elle détonne un peu dans le
paysage parce que je pense notamment à
ce maire
à ce maire qui relève de la compagnie de
Pornic qui appelle régulièrement le
commandant de le commandant de compagnie
parce que sommaire a été agressé dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions de mer avec
une fluidité une fluidité des échanges
qu'on a effectivement pas retrouvé à
Saint-Brevin alors qu'il y avait des
relations particulièrement fluides avec
avec les équipes municipales merci en
général monsieur usine une minute 50 pas
plus une minute trente même pas plus le
président merci beaucoup je voulais
juste revenir sur l'effet de 2016
effectivement vous n'étiez pas en
fonction 2016 c'était à 7 ans mais ce
n'était pas un cambriolage ni des
carreaux qu'on cassé c'était les tirs à
balles réelles donc il me semble que ce
genre d'événement dans une commune comme
ça c'est quelque chose qui doit marquer
les esprits des gendarmes qui sont sur
place sur le fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu
plus d'échanges avec le maire de
Saint-Brevin je ne dis pas que c'est
l'explication mais ça peut être l'une
des explications c'est un maire en
activité c'est un maire une activité qui
fait une activité qui est très
chronophage vous le savez c'était le
médecin de la commune et donc moi je le
vois dans mon département lorsque les
mers sont en activité ils délègue
beaucoup alors adjoints et ça peut être
l'une des
enfin je voulais attirer vous remercier
pour tout ce que vous faites depuis les
faits particulièrement graves qui ont
conduit le maire de Saint-Brevin a
démissionné je sais la campagnement que
vous avez fait mis en œuvre pour le
maire de la commune ne il faut pas que
l'adjointe au maire en charge des
affaires scolaires soit dans un angle
mort parce qu'elle subit des pressions
très très importantes puisque
effectivement c'est elle qui a en charge
les affaires scolaires et n'oubliez pas
s'il vous plaît les deux plaintes qui
ont été déposés le 3 février à savoir
celle de Monsieur Croze et son
vice-président ils ne sont pas élus mais
ils sont aussi soumis au même pression
merci Monsieur bon je suis messieurs les
généraux merci finalement merci pour
votre présence ce matin pour la
précision de vos réponses et nous vous
souhaitons une excellente journée merci
à vous nous reprenons dans quelques
minutes